hi Shan I'd like to connect my cloud run
service to other resources in my VPC
Network how do I set that up hi Martin
okay so you've got a bunch of resources
running in your own virtual Network on
Google Cloud right yep uh I have a
Reddit cache and my company also has a
database hosted on a virtual machine got
it so let me show you how to connect
your Cloud run service to resources in a
VPC or a virtual private Cloud Network
we now have a great new feature where
you can connect directly instead of
proxying it through a
[Music]
connector shawen you are a product
manager for cloud run uh focusing on
networking and security right that's
right and as a product manager I hear
from customers who want to make calls
from cloud run to other resources in
their VPC Network or attached to their
VPC Network these resources can be
virtual machines databases memory story
instances and even on Prem systems and
I'm happy to say that this is now much
easier to do great uh how does it work
when you create a new Cloud run service
you can decide which VPC Network it
should be able to send traffic to here
is one of my cloud run Services it can
send traffic to the default VPC Network
I see and connecting directly like this
is probably easier than what we had to
do before right yes it's easier to set
up and your traffic will be faster too
we have heard from a lot of customers
who really like the direct connectivity
for example K4 said that it simplifies
their architecture aligns with their pay
as you go model and it improves the
total cost of ownership of their
pipelines excellent I like it when
things become easier and faster now I
built a simple rest API in Cloud run uh
the rest API returns artists from a
database uh for example when I hit this
end
point it returns freed Dark Hollow one
of my favorite artists H that felt a bit
slow uh yes and that's where the cache
comes in I'd like to speed up my API by
caching artists in a reddis cache and
there is a Google Cloud product called
memory store it's a managed redis
instance and do you have a store
instance already yep there it is uh when
I set it up I had to fill out which VPC
network is should belong to uh I picked
default here uh is that fine yes let's
use that your memory store instance will
be reachable from the ivpc the default
network was automatically created for
your project all right uh I updated my
source code to check the cache first
whenever rest API is called uh now how
do I configure my cloud run service so
it can connect to the memory store
instance first go to your Cloud run
service in the
console then click edit and deploy new
revision pick
networking check connect to a VPC for
outbound
traffic here you can choose either
serverless VPC access connectors or you
can send traffic directly to a
VPC let's pick that second option and
select the default Network and
subnet you remember that our memory
store instance is on the def default VPC
Network so we want our Cloud run service
to connect to that Network got it uh
what should I write in the network tags
field that field is optional you can
write something that lets you identify
the service let's enter front end for
now we'll come back to this later now
deploy the
updates nice uh that was super easy yep
and can you click on the networking tab
uh sure uh here we go
uh ah uh I see it shows the network the
subnet and the network tag that I
configured should we check that it works
oh right let's do that uh let's hit the
service and ask for Freeda Caro
again okay we got a reply and it was
pretty slow um now let's do it again uh
now the cache should help us there it is
uh much faster than the previous time
the cach seems to be working fine great
yes indeed uh but I have a few questions
for you Shan sure I know a lot of our
reviewers uh also have Services running
on Prem and those services are connected
to their VPC in Google Cloud can Cloud
run also connect uh hit those on Prem
systems using this new feature we just
looked at yes as long as the on preme
systems are connected to your Google
Cloud VPC using either Cloud
interconnect or a VPN got it next
question how much does this VPC
connectivity cost uh not just for
calling from cloud run to on-prem
systems but also for cloud run calling
memory store Cloud SQL virtual machines
and so on glad you asked there's no
fixed monthly cost you'll pay for
traffic going from your Cloud run
service just like you'd pay for traffic
from a virtual machine in the VPC and
it's charged at the same rate and if I'm
using any serverless VPC connectors in
my project today I can switch my cloud
round Services over to this direct
access and remove those connectors
uh because that would lower my cloud
bill right yes for sure and some
customers have done that already uh but
before you do so be aware that as of
this recording this feature is still in
preview so I shouldn't use it for my
production workloads just yet right
exactly and it currently comes with some
limitations many of them will go away
when this feature goes to General
availability and I see a preview Banner
here uh that will go away when it hits
General availability yes check that
Banner or the release notes for the
status of this feature sounds great all
right next question uh one of my
projects has several Cloud run jobs that
run every night they do database cleanup
and such uh can these Cloud run jobs
connect directly to VPC as well yes they
can and what about Cloud functions Cloud
functions second generation can connect
directly as well you have to set Direct
VPC egress on the functions underlying
Cloud run service excellent uh my next
question is about fine grained access uh
let's say I have a sensitive Erp system
also running in my VPC and to play it
really safe I don't want my cloud run
service to be able to reach that Erp
system how would I set that up you can
do that with firewall rules remember how
you set the network tag front end when
you configured VPC access oh right you
told me to yeah yeah you can Define
firewall rules based on network tags so
you can for example Define a rule that
blocks traffic from front end to
resources tagged Erp ah very good uh now
about IP addresses any virtual machine
on my VPC will use an IP address I know
that much uh will my cloud run service
also use these internal IP addresses yes
they will you can run this command to
see which IP addresses have been
allocated from your subnet you can also
see these IP addresses here in the cloud
console under VPC Network IP addresses
got it and can I write firewall rules
based on those IP addresses no not quite
those IP addresses are dynamically
allocated and can change at any time
you're better off writing firewall rules
based on network tags just like we
talked about Network tags got it uh what
if my cloud run service scales up it
gets low of traffic I guess it would use
more internal IP addresses uh can I run
out of them that's a great question
Cloud run pre-allocate IPS to make
scaling up faster you need to make sure
there are enough IPS available on your
subnet my rule of thumb is that you
should have at least a few hundred IP
addresses available if the subn Net's
total number of instances across all
Cloud run services and jobs grows beyond
100 then multiply the max instance count
by four and make sure there are at least
that many internal IP addresses
available well I'm not really a
networking guy uh could I just use the
default VPC Network in subnet guess what
if your company does not have a
networking guy or gal then the default
VPC and subnet will almost certainly
work for you IP address exhaustion
typically becomes an issue in more
advanced networking setups such as if
you're managing a single shared VPC
connecting together services from
hundreds or more projects
in that case you can read our
documentation to learn more about
additional options ah all right uh let's
recapt show and what are the takeaways
your Cloud run Services can now access
resources in a VPC directly in a way
that's easier and faster and you will
also reduce your bill and your system
complexity when you get rid of your
serverless VPC access connectors if
you're going to use this new feature in
production check the documentation first
and make sure it has graduated from
preview to General availability I will
try it out for my cloud round Services
it's just a few clicks after all I think
anyone watching this should try it out
as well thanks for joining me today Shan
thanks for having me Martin and thank
you everyone for watching if you have
questions for shaan or me please add a
comment below also let me know if there
are other servess topics you'd like to
see in future episodes I read every
single comment until next time
[Music]
time